good evening and welcome to the planning
committee of Stratford on Avon District
Council my name is Council Lewis Adam
I'm your chairman for this evening I'd
like to start with some housekeeping uh
we're not expecting a fire alarm this
evening so if one goes off uh please uh
leave in an orderly way to the exit and
it's
um the car park by the windmill Pub
across the road is where we check off
your names uh can you all make sure that
your phones are either turned off or on
silent uh just so that they don't
disturb the flow of the meeting
uh this meeting is being recorded and
live streamed on our website uh it is a
meeting meeting in public not a public
meeting which means that those only
those who are registered to speak are
able to do so are the appropriate time
they'll be called up and given
instructions from there I would like to
now introduce the uh the top table uh
we've got on my right from democratic
Services Kira Keller and Olivia Quinn
we've got our solicitor Amy Shipley and
on my left we've got planning manager
David Jeffrey and our presenting
officers this evening are Emma Booker
and Sarah Sarah Flaherty and now I
believe David has a statement he'd like
to say
thank you chair my name is David Jeffrey
I'm the planning manager for tonight's
meeting my role is to provide impartial
advice to clarify any planning issues
that arise and to assist members
decision taking
planning committee members are not bound
by advice from officers or by their
recommendations thank you chair
thank you very much in that case we can
move on to our agenda
item one apologies for absence
much item two disclosures of Interest
are there any members with disclosures
of Interest councilor Parry
thank you and thank you chair and good
evening
um I would just like to declare an
interest I shall be speaking on
application 22 forward slash zero three
two eight o forward slash ful 29 the
close Hampton Lucy and we'll be stepping
down from the committee
lovely thank you very much any more
decorations of Interest really good in
that case we'll move on to our first
item item number three which is
application
23-00581 out the yard green Lanes Allen
Hall
and our presenting officer is Emma
Booker and when you're ready take it
away thank you very much
thank you chair so I'm presenting the
first item on the agenda it is for
outline planning permission for the
erection of one dwelling which is a
self-build with all matters reserved
except for the details of the access
the application site is um outside the
village of Ellen hall near Henley and
Arden
we're in a green belt location in the
open Countryside and we're also in the
special landscape area of Arden you can
see the application site is that um
signified by the black dot
site plan the application site is the
site etched in red the land outlined in
blue is also within the ownership of the
applicant but not subject of this
application
you can see that it's labeled the yard
to the north of the site that
accommodates a business use
um which is a I believe it's a
secondhand car dealership
proposed site plan and this is an
indicative layout so we're not assessing
the layout but you can see that they are
proposing a detached dwelling with a
detached garage and an area for parking
on this side plan as well you can see
the belt of Conifer trees which exist at
the site which are proposed to be
retained in the parcel edged in blue
um they are proposing biodiversity
enhancement so they're proposing to
plant grassland Meadow sorts of
enhancements
Google
um aerial photo now shows the
application site within its cotton text
um outside of the village again I've
already said open Countryside and green
belt location
this is zoomed in so you can see the
business use at the North End of the
site the dwelling is um and you'll see
on the site photos it's just in an open
grass area
First Sight photo so this is where the
the dwelling is proposed these conifers
that you can see are proposed to be
retained
this is looking back in the other
direction towards the the road
again where the where the dwelling is
proposed and the relationship with the
neighbor property
Street Scene
um
members of you know your attention is
drawn to the fact that there's no
pavement within this street scene
um it's very much a country road that
leads into the village of Ellen Hall
oh I'm standing where the dwelling will
be built now looking back towards Henley
and Arden so you can see that that
Hedgerow that defines the boundary of
the site
and then this next photo I've just
popped my camera over it so you you know
you can appreciate the open landscape
Beyond
and that concludes my presentation thank
you oh I should say sorry we've got no
updates
um but I've recommended refusal for this
application on two grounds
um one of them is Green Belt harm and
the other relates to the unacceptable
location or inappropriate location we
don't deem it to be a suitable location
for a new dwelling thank you
thank you very much Emma
um so moving on to our speakers uh we
have the applicant
um John Clayton and agent Reuben Bellamy
if you'd like to move forwards
so you've got three minutes uh between
you
um my writing suggesting that
Mr Bellamy you'll be speaking
lovely thank you well in that case when
you're ready you can start I'll give you
a 30 second warning
thank you chairman ladies and gentlemen
Mr Clayton is a long-term local resident
with strong ties to the area he's hoping
to build a self-build dwelling on an old
Builder's yard
development on this site is in line with
policy as 10 of the movement plan as it
has not come to the overall development
strategy it meets the local housing need
utilizes previously developed Brownfield
land and helps to address the council's
short form in self-built housing
these matters we say are all material
considerations of significant weight and
support of the application
references made in the office of report
regarding a housing needs survey policy
as10 does not require a full needs
survey in every case other forms of
evidence are acceptable
since 2011 we think only one possibly
two dwelling dwellings have been built
in the parish
given this low number it is no surprise
that the parish put forward the case
that a housing need exists the lack of a
formal needs survey is not evidence of
no need we have the evidence of the
parish response and we know that Mr
Clayton requires a self-build dwelling
the site has a lawful development
certificate as a builder's yard it does
contain fixed surface infrastructure in
that there is a tile map track along one
side of it the workshop buildings to the
rear were also once part of the site
therefore for these reasons the site
meets the definition of Brownfield in
the nppf
this application proposes utilizing only
one part of the Builder's yard as you
saw in the drawings
the site's lawful commercial use for the
whole site provides a fallback position
of considerable weight as the impact of
the storage of materials equipment and
all the associated activity could be
significant in contrast the impact of a
single cell build dwelling on part of
the Builder's yard will be modest in
terms of openness and the remainder of
the old will be returned to Meadow
providing a 45 biodiversity net gain
now the event we say there are very
special circumstances to outweigh any
limited harm these include to help
address the lack of self-build dwellings
a mass that which this committee has
given significant weight to in the past
the use of previously developed land
meeting a local housing need for a
resident of the parish 45 net gain in
biodiversity
it removes the right to a commercial use
which could be problematic for the
adjacent residential property and the
appearance of the green belt the traffic
generation will be no greater than
lawful use and not involve large
commercial vehicles on Rural roads and
we're proposing a highly sustainable
dwelling Mr Clayton is committed to
building a zero carbon home
this situation is probably unique in the
district a local resident with a long
connection wishes to build a zero carbon
30 seconds on a builder's yard
Parish support the application and state
that there is a local need and a
significant area is being proposed by
diversity Net game we respectfully ask
that members support the application
thank you very much
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our applicant Arrangement yes
counselor Perry
thank you chair and good evening
um I was just interested to know what
sort of consultation had been made with
the parish council and perhaps the
question of of them or or why they
haven't carried out
um a local housing needs survey has any
any dialogue taken place because
normally Parish councils on a regular
basis will do a housing needs survey to
provide evidence for local housing needs
no the um the local Parish Council
hasn't carried out the survey we did so
several years ago but this time around I
believed that they didn't think it was
it was deemed necessary we have several
large houses well we've had several
large houses built within the district
over the last 20 20 odd years 23 years
um we we think that probably fulfills
most of our needs anyway
however I believe that this one is a
unique situation
it would
alleviate take away a builder's yard and
apply to the Builder's yard it would
give a sustainable home to myself and
the wife for the rest of our retirement
we we believe that
we could then free up a large
four-bedroom house which you live in at
the moment in the village
for rather residents a large family to
move in
thank you very much are there any other
questions from members uh councilor
Harvey
thank you chairman the officers report
makes the statement that the it refers
to a scrap yard as opposed to builders
yard but I assume it's the same thing
that this scrap yard as he puts it oh
she puts it hasn't operated since 1999.
and that uh
the opinion is of the officer the demand
for such use on this site is has a very
low probability and therefore the
committee should attach very limited
weight to the claimed fallback position
could you give me any evidence or
reasons why you would disagree with that
if I start with the sort of the
say the technical planning aspects and
John used to be a building I think so we
can probably answer on the the market
demand be like so I mean yes the office
is right in terms of for a fallback
position to carry some weight yeah
there's got to be some uh probability
that it might actually happen
um what we say is that legally it can
happen you know we could operate a
builder's yard tomorrow
um John I'm coming here but my
understanding is that he hasn't been
pushing it a builders on for a long time
um the project now is to try and get a
self-built dwelling on there but if that
doesn't happen
um
over to you John your intentions with
the land would be well I think it leaves
it open for me to to actually uh offer
it for rent I or I retired 10 years ago
or just over 10 years ago
um and then and then I rented out the
two units up until then it was a build
Builders yard although I didn't actually
utilize the rest of the land
however because of of
a useless rental Lincoln
um I believe that I think the option the
fallback option would be to to actually
rent out the existing well this part of
the land to actually uh become we build
a Shard again but I think there are
plenty takers for that the opportunity
to use about three quarters of an acre
for industrial use which is is it's B1
so there's no reason why it couldn't be
used to build a storage
hard hardstanding and Builder stories
right the way through
thank you chairman any other questions
uh Castle Fleming
introduction of this potential dwelling
that you're going to build and have you
thought of climate change uh
facilities within that house how are you
going to sort of help with they you
talked about biodiversity other than
that but have you got any other uh other
things that you want to build into the
house to make it a sustain a sustainable
house
I mean the it the intention is that we
we are
looking to hit Net Zero basically in
terms of the building obviously this is
just outlined so we haven't got details
of yet that yet but you know if if we're
fortunate enough to get outline position
the reserve that stage we will be
detailing how we'll achieve Net Zero um
now obviously there's a range of
Technologies we don't know what the
exactly what they're going to be yet but
it's going to be a mix I would have
thought normally of you know
photovoltaics air source heat pumps that
sort of thing rainwater recycling all
those sorts of things that we determine
that quite happy to accept a condition
or at some point you know in a 106 to
um to commit to to hitting that Net Zero
obviously we'd meet all your other
policies that you've got at the moment
such as
um the electric vehicle charging and
those matters
you have any other questions for
applicants
no in which case thank you very much
and we'll move on to another speaker
it's only good so our next speaker is
the ward member counselor shenton
hello councilor shenton
um
you have five minutes and I'm sure you
know I'll give you a 30 second
warning otherwise take it away when
you're ready
thank you chair and good evening to all
members of the committee you've read in
the the comprehensive reasons why the
previous Ward member supported this
application and no doubt have read the
various reports that accompany it except
for the planners report there are no
objections to remind you of some of the
more pertinent points there are no core
strategy policies covering self-build
therefore any self-built application
will come up against existing policies
such as CS 1516 and as10 however as
there are no policies within the core
strategy that provide specific guidance
for the council's legal obligation to
maintain a three-year role in supply of
self-build and custom house building I
therefore think that CS 1516 and as10
offer very limited weight
in planning terms we don't distinguish
between self-built and custom house
building however this application
appears to represent the original reason
this legislation was red legislation was
brought in and self builds tend to be
built Beyond an above minimum
environmental standards and implement
the latest housing Technologies
in respect to the benefits the
development would provide a custom House
Bill dwelling at a time when the council
has a significant shortfall could you
move on to the two slides sorry uh
therefore a significant shortfall of 76
which the officer does agree with this
is a significant weight and weighs
heavily in favor of granting planning
permission for such schemes and next
slide please
any railway station like in terms of
location is located about a thousand
meters away there are various direct
walks within the countryside and
Pathways which lead directly into Henley
next slide please
as we know this is one of those rarer
applications which has the support of
the parish council the previous District
Council myself and most importantly
members of the community because these
are the people who are affected by any
development
in terms of statutory consultees there
are no objections in fact WCC the County
Council ecology Say by biodiversity Net
game could be achieved by enhancing the
neighboring grassland which is in the
ownership of the applicant again the
officer agrees with this assessment
housing needs survey which was brought
up the SPD states that evidence of the
identification of needs for a local
needs housing scheme will usually be in
the form of a local housing needs survey
this implies that it does not always
have to be and helpfully the officer
acknowledges this
this application could bring a new
dwelling into the housing stock and free
up a family home
fallback position next slide please
there is a lawful use of the site as a
builder's yard
as we can see from there from from the
past this means it can be turned back
into one at any time this is also
evidencing in the granted 2013
application which shows the location of
the existing building yard site
the plan to say is there's no evidence
that the fallback position is a real
probability but let's not forget that
the planning permission exists for such
use there is nothing to stop this
becoming a reality it's therefore a
permissible credible and real fallback
position
material planning math is always
difficult to go against officers
recommendations
um well I'm going to give you a couple I
hope that might help the office of first
reason the officer says the development
conflicts with SDC core policies there's
been new legislation since the course
strategy the 2016 self-built custom and
house building act which we've as far as
spoke about earlier SDC has a legal
obligation to provide self and custom
build sites and we're unfortunately
short on numbers
second reason we've seen in evidence in
photographs and previous planning
applications that this is previously
developed land this is important in this
application you can therefore choose to
decide that this is not inappropriate
development or encroaching into the open
Countryside
there are special circumstances the
fallback position of a builder's yard is
the significant one freeing up a larger
house in a village for a family creation
of a highly sustainable dwelling
the applicants has a very long and local
connection to the area and 45 net
biodiversity gain collectively these
outweigh any harm to the open
Countryside 30 seconds the officer
mentions this is this will not do much
for the numbers of self builds which SDC
has a legal obligation to provide I
challenge that because any application
would go would help that number each
application is judged on its own merits
the choice is obviously yours there are
no objections from anyone to an
application that can only improve the
potential impact of the open Countryside
for the future
thank you for listening to me
perfect timing look at that thank you
very much uh councilor shenton members
do we have any questions uh councilor
Harvey
all right councilor shenton I tried to
listen very carefully to your five
minutes minus one second
I don't think you used the words green
belt
why not
very sorry I mean I partly because if
I'd use green belt in open Countryside
in the same I would have been over the
five minutes so I cut it this down as I
was going along but as far as great the
the main objection is that it it's it's
green belt around and it's in the open
Countryside well we have within the uh
and the the planner acknowledges this
within the green belt and in this area
it's not uncommon to have one or two
houses isolated from Main Villages this
is normal this is normal within the
countryside so whether it's Greenbelt
open Countryside or the the Arden
special landscape area
have the odd house like this or two
houses
as it would be with uh with green Lanes
next door to it is not an unusual
circumstance
councilor Keithley yeah councilor
shankton thank you for that
um I've got a question of clarification
um
about
the evidence of occupation of that site
by permanent structures and I think you
flashed up a photograph which showed
some buildings could we see that again
could you perhaps explain what those
buildings are
you are asking the wrong person you
really need to ask
um the applicant about those buildings
those are the buildings on site taken
from uh years ago but that's what it
looks like if it if you like when it was
a builder's yard
and in theory well this was yeah thank
you this was part of your presentation
so do you know when those when the
photograph was taken I think in from
memory that was taken back in the 1980s
late night mid 1980s something like that
is that right
okay thanks
are there any other questions to our war
member
no in that case thank you very much
councilor shenton
okay uh so that's it for our speakers in
which case we're moving on to points of
clarification from our officer I'm just
going to start uh with that one
um
Emma can you tell me how much weight can
we apply to the self-build aspect of
this application considering it's within
the green belt
foreign
the self-built aspect of the development
is a material consideration
um
the you've heard the speakers advise
that the council's core strategy does
not contain policy related to self-build
and for those reasons
officer's view is that policies relating
to new development and house building in
the district
cs15 as10 and the like only can be
afforded moderate weight in that respect
there remain a raft of policies in the
course strategy including cs10 on
Greenbelt which retain full weight
thank you very much David any other
questions councilor Parry
the officers could give some
clarification on the point in policy
cs10 green belt with regard to the
limiting infilling or the partial or
complete Redevelopment of a previously
developed Brownfield site weather
redundant or in continuing use if if the
site we are looking at is a is a a
former's Builders yard
thereby is that not considered
Brownfield as part of cs10
yes happy to try and clarify that point
um I think you've seen the photo of the
site which we have and there are various
other aerial photos of this site which
um show it as a green grassland over a
period of time
we're not sure where that photo was
taken precisely on the site
but nevertheless our own core strategy
and the nppf contain a definition of
previously developed land which requires
occupation of the land by permanent
structures
whether existing or previously
we don't think that this meets that test
this particular area of the site where
they're proposing their their new
dwelling
um the
nppf and cs10 in respect of green belt
talks about the Redevelopment of
Brownfield land but only in the context
of Redevelopment which preserves the
openness of Greenbelt Land
so our view on that is that The Proposal
even if you do accept that it's
Brownfield land would have a greater
impact on openness than anything that
has previously existed on the sides or
which could exist on the site under the
lawful development certificate for
a builder's yard
we also
taking it a step further
in terms of it being a theoretical
fallback position we have to be
convinced that it passes a test of being
a greater than a theoretical possibility
of this being implemented and as we've
gone through in the report it it has
existed on site to lawful development
certificate for a long time for this to
be a builder's yard and there has never
been any use of this site from the
aerial images that we have that show it
having been used for Ability guard in
the last 30 years I think
so we think that that's less than a
theoretical probability at this stage
thank you councilor Harvey thank you
chairman can I refer to page seven of
the report of the papers and references
made to cs15
um and that development is restricted to
small-scale community schemes which meet
a need identified by the local community
later on on the page there are four
bullet points on my reading it is clear
that bullet points three and four seem
to be met by this application I eat
an applicant from a who has a connection
to the parish and it it is it is one
unit I eat small scale
I have there were some questions about
how how you ever what evidence is
acceptable to prove that this represents
a local need
um
there are there is this
weasel word usually
um which the uh applicants have have
referred to can you give the committee
any assistance on how it should fairly
interpret the evidence that we have
which seems to me to be assertions
assertions of the individual and of the
parish council and and of the the ward
member is that sufficient from our
purpose that we can take that as
evidence of of need and how often is
usually I not not relying upon a local
needs housing needs survey how often is
usually referred to
I'd say in most applications where
they're made on the grounds of it
meeting a local need so in the majority
of it is backed up by a local needs
survey so they are usually carried out
by the parish council and they go
through a robust assessment so it has to
be a genuine need so it's different from
a local person saying I would like a new
house in in my Village it goes through
um what exactly is needed by the local
people tenure
um they look at bedrooms or number you
know the size of the dwelling and then
they will make an assessment of whether
you know development has been
forthcoming which may have met that need
so it's it's a robust report which then
we use as evidence in our assessment we
would look at planning history in the
area have there been four bedroom houses
delivered which could meet that need
um so in this case we don't have that
all that I've been presented with is an
aspiration by an applicant to build a
house for a local person but I wouldn't
say that that is a local need dwelling
would you agree I would agree with all
of that yes I'd probably go a step
further to say that there isn't a local
needs assessment for this location
because it doesn't sit within a local
service Village or a recognized
settlement in a sec in essence it sits
in the open Countryside where you know
that explains why a local needs survey
hasn't been done because it's not it's
not ordinarily considered that there are
local needs arising unless they are very
specific
thank you chair
um I'd just like to better understand
uh the weight that you're attaching to
cs10 in respect of the green belt and
the Redevelopment of a potential
Brownfield site I think I've read that
you afford that considerable weight but
could you explain to us the cs10
policy on the weight attached to it in
this case please
so in this case the cs10 attracts full
weight the fact that it's a self-build
doesn't diminish the significance of
that policy in our assessment
it's a green belt policy and the mppf is
clear that we need to attach substantial
weight to any harm to the green belt
that arises so in the planning balance
we give significant weight or you know
full weight to that policy
do you have any other questions for
officers Castle Fleming
just a quick one really
um this potential development can it be
seen from anywhere are there any
footpaths close by I mean it's well
screened with these these tall trees and
whatever else I just wonder that we're
talking about harming the green belt now
going to be seen from anywhere where
that's going to cause people a problem
with time to the green belt
I'd say that it's it's highly visible in
the landscape
um it will be visible from the
surrounding Fields there is a footpath
that runs north to south and you can see
on this plan
I don't know if I can point to it the
footpath runs down this road in between
the application site and green Lanes so
it will be it will be visible
any other questions for officers
in which case we can move into the
debate who would like to start
I'll pick a name Council Parry thank you
here we go
um
I think this is quite a
complex application and obviously has
full support
from the parish and the ward member and
residents but the big thing for me is
that it is open Countryside it is in the
Greenbelt and more importantly what what
I'm struggling with is that we have a
lack of evidence for the local need
if there had been a housing needs survey
that identified this particular need
I would feel that
together wage with the self-build and
other side of things would carry a lot a
loss of weight but where I'm sitting at
the moment
um I'm inclined to go with the officer's
recommendation because of this lack of
evidence
um and and the various policies that
stack up against it with a open
Countryside and green belt and I just
feel that if there was this local needs
housing needs survey that identified
this specific need despite being out of
the main village I feel that would give
me more comfort
to go the other way but I'll see what my
other colleagues have to say
thank you very much uh councilor Curtis
next I believe
um not disagreeing with anything Council
Powers just said but I'm just I've got a
couple of comments on on the on the
report and we've talked about the
housing needs survey
um but I think we've all set on these
committees where there have been very
robust housing needs surveys
and they've not always been given due
weight in any case so I'm
I I'm not convinced that the lack of a
former housing needs survey necessarily
Canada is a great deal of weight
um and just on page eight
um the comment from the officer there's
a little doubt in my mind that future
occupants of the dwelling built in this
location would be holding reliant on
private motor vehicle
um there are no shops as far as I'm
aware in the local Village anyway so
residents living in Ireland Hall are
reliant though or the resident in were
permission granted for this and the
resident here will be a no dissimilar
position to those living in on island
Hall in any case so just a couple of
comments to throw in thank you
thank you very much councilor Keithley
next I believe yeah thank you chair
um I think listening to the evidence
from the applicants and the officers I
I'm I'm not persuaded that the need
argument for this self-build in this
location
um
overweighs the weight given to policies
cs10 on the green belt and the harm that
that would be inflicted on that area
because it's highly visible and I'm also
concerned about its location because
it's quite a long way from the
settlements there's no public footpath
um it's an isolated rural appears to me
to be an isolated rural site
um so uh the way I'm feeling about this
is uh I'm I'm I'm feeling that um I'm in
agreement with the recommendation of the
officer
is that the proposal yes I would like to
make that proposal
thank you very much councilor Harvey
thank you chairman
um
my start point is that this is an
application in the green belt and the
green belt is not synonymous despite
councilor shenton's assertion the green
belt is not synonymous with open
Countryside they are different and the
officers I think correctly have have
come to the conclusion that this site is
unsuitable for a new new Housing
Development and therefore it's
unacceptable in principle and I note
that
um
we are instructed as a local Authority
that we should not approve proposals in
the green belt unless there are very
special circumstances to go against that
and in this particular instance uh
attention is also drawn to paragraph 149
of the nppf and I note that in the
second bullet point on page page nine in
the papers that
there is on the question of identified
need there is a requirement under
paragraph 149 G
that this any proposal would have to
contribute to meeting an identified
affordable housing need
which this isn't I can't see an
overwhelming reason at all to go against
the officer's recommendation and if a
proposal has been made I'm quite happy
to Second it
okay thank you very much anyone else
want to speak on this item
I think I think
for my thoughts I I broadly agree with
everything that's been said I can
certainly see the desire to develop this
site from the applicant's point of view
but
um looking at the very thorough work
done by the officers on this I can't see
the significant weight to go against our
policies on Greenbelt uh okay so in that
case we have a proposal and a seconder
and that is to
go to refuse the application in line
with the officer's recommendations
could I see all those in favor please
and that's unanimous
okay in that case this committee
um
resolves to refuse application
2300581 out the art green lanes are
learn Hall
thank you
okay
all right so we're now moving on to item
number four which is application
2300123 slash ful Hillcrest Hillcrest
Benton Road Welford on Avon
and our presenting officer is again Emma
Booker and when you're ready Emma feel
free to take it away
thank you right next
um as has been said we've got an
application at Hillcrest we are in uh
Wellford upon even the application site
is denoted by the black dot we are in
the built up area boundary of Welford
and the proposal is for full planning
permission for one dwelling
application site as shown on the slide
edged in Red so the proposal is for
development within the residential
Garden of a dwelling called Hillcrest
so a large-scale site plan here you can
see the dwelling to the
um east of the application site
Hawthorne house that was a previous
development that was built out by the
owners of Hillcrest so they have already
developed part of their Garden this
application seeks to do another Garden
development
aerial photo to show you the context
um application site is the red circle
you can see that the road that runs to
the south of the site that is called
Church bank and there's been new
development that has created this sort
of Riven development up that road
so we've recommended approval for this
on the basis that it would the proposal
would conform to that established um
development character
um again I've just zoomed in so you can
see Hawthorne house which is um the more
recent build to the east of the
application site and Hillcrest to the
west and you can see that it's infilling
a gap in between those two dwellings
post site plan I'm sorry
um so I've included this on the slide to
show you that the detached dwelling
would have a detached garage it would
have a side on relationship with
Hillcrest the applicants live in the on
the plot that's edged in Blue part of
the proposal for the new dwelling is to
provide a vehicle passing point because
the access up to Thorn of Hawthorne
house as existing is quite narrow so the
highway officer requested that they have
a wider access at the junction with
Benton Road so we have secured that
floor plans and we've got no concerns
related to the internal environment of
this dialing we consider it to be high
quality
elevations I would say that the
applicant has engaged very proactively
with myself to arrive at a design that
we consider acceptable
side elevations
this slide is useful just to illustrate
in the relationship the The Proposal
would have you can see that the
topography slopes upwards from Hillcrest
which is on Benton Road up towards um
Hawthorne house and and that new ribbon
development Beyond so you can see the
spacing between all the um all the
dwellings
put some photos to show you now so the
photos on the left hand side two and
four are the existing dwelling at
Hillcrest number three which shows you
where the application development is
proposed in that garden with Hawthorne
house in the background
and then number five is it's all phone
house
I've put this in just to show members
where what it would be this is crude but
it shows you where it would sit within
the binton road Street Scene so it's
obviously behind the White House in the
foreground but that shows where it would
go
so here you can see the access on the
left so that's going to be shared by
Hawthorne house and the proposed
development
this is where the vehicle passing place
is being laid out and then you've got
church bank which is the road on the on
the right hand side of that which leads
up to those larger dwellings
access so this is proposed to be surface
bound and we're going to secure we've
we've recommended to secure that by
condition
and then that's all that I have to show
so thank you
we're recommending approval for this
application thank you
thank you very much Emma okay we'll move
on to our first Speaker then who is
councilor Neil Appleton from Wellford on
Avon Parish Council
our house wrapped and I think I've seen
you here before um you should know the
drill you've got three minutes I'll give
you a 30 second warning and you can
start when you're ready thank you very
much
okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
um National policy and guidance weigh
heavily in favor of granting planning
permission for self-builds in
appropriate locations
this is not an appropriate location the
inclusion of a second property in the
back Garden of Hillcrest is an over
development in the context of the
settlement pattern of the locality
the locality is bounded by the public
Highway of Benton Road and two private
roads two Acre Lane and church Bank
the vernacular
along the Benton Road is a detached
dwellings with large rear Gardens
currently the dwelling at Hillcrest
informs and conforms with this
vernacular
the additional dwelling will increase
the settlement density and is therefore
contrary to policy hlu5
the dwelling faces Church bank and the
grain of development conforms with the
neighboring property at Hawthorne house
the PC agree that this is correct
the case officer's view is that this has
no impact on binton Road
however on this the PC disagree
two doors down the road at Rosslyn an
attempt to build a two-bedroom Bungalow
in a larger Rio Garden was refused by
Stratford District Council and dismissed
the appeal
and this was despite the dwelling being
invisible to the public domain
in this regard the objection was down to
the shared access
currently the access is a private drive
to a single property a Hawthorne house
in serving an additional dwelling the
drive becomes a shared Private Road
it is only three meters wide
this is contrary to the requirements of
the fire service who raise no objection
provided that the access is 3.7 meters
wide
The Proposal fails to conform with the
2019 housing needs survey for welfare on
Avon
this stipulated new building of five
open market two-bedroom bungalows
this was to meet the need of an aging
population with accessibility needs and
wishing to downsize
this is a four bedroom house over two
floors
it exceeds both the number of bedrooms
and the number of floors
the PC objects further on the grounds of
cs-16
00 homes was the number of dwellings
that needed to be built in Category 2
lsvs
Welford has contributed 219 of that
total in so doing it has grown 30
percent from a village of 600 homes to
over 800.
this is not sustainable
Stratford's five years thank you
Stratford's five-year land Supply means
a presumption in favor of sustainable
development is not engaged they're not
my words they're the words of the
inspector who dismissed the appeal at
Rosaline
I have a few additional points there is
no indication in the plans how shared
access will be managed the case officer
claims that the landscape plan may
result in a biode diversity net gain but
there's no evidence to back this up
and ecology has an advisory that has not
been included in the conditions or notes
if you have any questions please do ask
thank you very much thank you very much
just on time what
um members do we have any questions for
our Parish Council
Curtis
thank you Chad good evening
um can you so
um there is a housing needs survey yes
can I just ask when that was completed
that was only 2019 2019. yes lovely
thank you very much thank you
any other questions for the parish
counselor
no in that case I believe you're free to
go thank you very much thank you
all right uh we're now moving on to our
next speaker who is James Reed on behalf
of the applicant Now understand that Mr
Reed won't be speaking but is available
for members questions is that right
in which case we can move straight to
questions for our agent does any member
have any questions
no couple of puzzle pieces Catholic
yeah weren't expecting that thank you
chair
um
I'd really like to understand the shared
access issue which I don't understand
really I I sort of photograph
a minute ago in
presentation that um
that the case officer put up which
showed the offense and the the church
Bank Road and the shared access to the
properties
we've just
if you no need to share it that's it
could you could you help us understand
what's happening to the width of this so
that that um the property that's going
to be served by this access as a joint
access is going to be suitable for
passing vehicles or or however that's
going to work thank you
good evening
um so any the proposed dwelling is
accessed by the the driveway which is on
the left photo which is a gruffal
driveway
um highways I've came back with now
recommendations on suitable whips
um we're happy for those to be complied
with by condition
as part of The Proposal we're including
a passing point and a bottom of the
gruffal driveway so that will allow two
cars to pass by
um side by side
and then the rest of the driveway is in
line with the conditions of Highways you
have no objects in
this is a follow-up only that that yeah
can you explain to us
how much space there is to
to widen that access because from the
photograph unless I can't see it
properly there doesn't seem to be much
room between the fence and the house now
this
um ability on either left-hand side
where we've got the timber fence on the
left now this ability to move that fence
over and to meet the requirements of
highways
so any requirements of Highways and the
3.7 we can achieve from that by moving
the the fence to the left
okay thank you yeah councilor Pemberton
I believe next
thank you chair and I'm following on
around the access
um so can you just so as I understand it
the current access is three meters wide
am I correct
so can you confirm in whose ownership
both sides of that driveway those fences
are who owns the fence
needing a fence on their left-hand side
is owned by our applicant
so that is an offense to
um Hillcrest
and then fence to the right hand side is
in a client
um ownership as well so he owns both
fence lines but it's only the boundary
of his ownership on the right hand side
I'm sorry so in the
applicant he owns the land of Whitney a
gruffle driveway is situated on
um he owns an offense on boat is erected
both fence lines on both sides of the
driveway
uh and so you're suggesting that as I
look at that the fence to the left-hand
side
um
the driveway can be widened to 3.7
meters along its entire length
is that what you're is that's can I just
clarify that
um so what's the other side of that
fence
um is probably for
um amenities base what is actually
physically the other side on that white
house
um so how can you demonstrate you can
actually widen this
because that looks to me like to achieve
it you've got to take the fence out
um I know I could be wrong
yeah not fence line will be relocated
opposed to provide a turning Circle as
required by fire service sorry Council
pempton I understand that this is
something that the officer's already
addressed in that it's going to be
conditioned based on the okay so I'm
just trying to understand how I I
appreciate your line of questioning but
I think I think
I will follow that line further
okay
do we have any other questions for our
agent
nope that case I think you're all done
thank you very much
okay uh we don't have our Ward member
registered to to speak in which case we
go on to point of clarification for our
officers uh councilor Harvey
can I ask the officer if she is
satisfied
that the requirements of the
Warwickshire fire and rescue service has
set out on page 24 can be met
yeah I'm satisfied it comply with that
councilor Pemberton
thank you um
I can just follow up
the the first criteria that's set out by
the Warwickshire lifestyle uh the
Warwickshire fire service is that they
can get within 45 meters
so provided that they have access that's
suitable to get their Appliance within
45 meters
we suggest that that's okay
thank you councilor Pemberton
I I'd like some clarification on that
um as I haven't seen the email or the
response from the fire service but as
as written that doesn't that seems to me
that it that the requirements are 45
meters the requirements are minimum
access 3.7 Gateway 3.1 height clearance
3.7 not any or the point I'm making is
the requirement seems to be the the
entire requirement I'm not convinced
that the fire service mean that if you
can get within 45 meters that's
sufficient
um so can I have some clarification
first of all from the officer can
can the applicant meet every single one
of those requirements because there's
nothing in that that says it's one or
other of them
I think that you probably would need to
see the content of the fire and safety
Rescue Services letter in its context of
only which part of it is recounted here
um we're satisfied that it does meet
those requirements fire rescue service
also request
um a note for inclusion in respect of
sprinklers
um
which is intended to uh delay fire
um in the event of an emergency which
also is imposed as a recommendation of
our condition of our recommendation as
well in the notes
um
this is consistent with uh
other developments which we've improved
elsewhere in the district and there's
been no objection from the fire and
rescue service
um I would also note that there are
other dwellings already of this access
so there's a level of betterment for
those as well arising from this
development in terms of fire safety
that's a members consideration
thank you thank you very much councilor
kitley thank you chair
um yes I'd like to
um just explore the impact of the
construction activity on the immunity of
the neighbors
so sometimes when you have shared access
on fairly narrow access issues then
construction activity can be quite a
burden upon people that live close by
and if they're sharing their access to
get in and out I'd like to understand
whether or not more than just what
you're what you've included in the
conditions is permitted hours of
construction but what I haven't included
is is a sort of construction management
plan that addresses the the needs to
take materials off-site like spoil and
stuff like that where skips are kept and
how materials like concrete get onto
site up a relatively narrow axis could I
ask a little bit more clarification on
on what what might be suggested or
proposed
if if members would like that included
in the conditions I wouldn't have any
objections so the permitted hours of
construction were made because we are in
a residential area but if you'd like to
go further and put in the construction
management plan condition I wouldn't
have any objection to that
any other questions for officers
in which case we've moved to the debate
who would like to start
because reading
thank you chair
um
I I understand wilford's pain in terms
of we seem to see them here every week
um bless them with their
their over meeting their housing needs
in various different ways
um my issue though is that I can't find
a really solid reason to go against the
officer's decision to my mind I don't
particularly think this is over
development
um unfortunately I think I think the the
management plan from highways looks
sound I think the design does actually
fit the vernacular of the um the street
scene
and and the picture that Emma put up
earlier of that
um was really really helpful so thank
you for that
um
all the consultations from interested
parties seem to be being met either with
no objection or by condition
um
I will be willing at this stage to
propose that we go along the lines of
Grant
in line with officers recommendations
but obviously I might be persuaded
otherwise
thank you very much councilor Keith
thank you chair
um yes I share the view of councilor
Eden um I'm concerned about the
construction phase
um and I would like to see a condition
attached that uh that brought more more
control to that phase than just the
permitted hours of construction but I'm
also
um interested in the possibility of the
applicants who look to maybe apply for a
self-built exemption on Sil to use this
opportunity to to build a very low
energy
and efficient home I'm not sure I've
seen very much about that I don't know
whether or not there are any conditions
that can be brought into play in that
area but I know we're beyond the point
of questioning
is that something that the officer could
comment on at this point or not
yeah I am very happy to
come on thank you chair
um I'd just draw attention to the
comments raised on page 29 in respect to
the council's climate change checklist
which is a requirement of uh
development requirements SPD we have
proposed that the
um
features of the dwelling which is
proposed which are talked about in that
climate change checklist are secured
through a condition so that's condition
12 of the recommendation
in which case I'd like to make a
proposal that's subject to those
conditions on a construction management
plan that we move to accept the
officer's recommendation on this
application
okay thank you very much I believe
counselor Curtis was next
yeah I think you probably know what I'm
going to say
here we've got a housing needs survey
which identifies a need for two-bedroom
Bungalows not a four bed dwelling
it just really does concern me and I've
said this on many occasions that
you know the previous application there
was no housing indeed survey so it was
felt
there was no evidence for what was
required here we've got a housing need
survey and we appear to be ignoring its
conclusions
I'm I'm really
what concerns me is that if we don't
give due weight to local housing needs
surveys people residents will feel well
what is the point of undertaking them
and all the work that is required to do
that
thank you very much councilor Perry
chair I think perhaps councilor
Pemberton had
all right thank you
um I'd like to Second councilor keeley's
proposal
um this is a self-build
um property
um we have no objection from any of the
consultes we have a shortage of
self-built properties it forms part of
the Riven the ribbon development that's
arising in Welford
um and therefore the self-build and
custom Housing Act trumps
as far as I'm concerned any local
housing needs survey due to the demand
and therefore I'm happy to Second this
proposal thank you chair thank you very
much councilor Pemberton uh thank you
chair
um like many members of the committee
eye
share some of the challenges that
Welford finds itself in which are
reflected in other communities as well I
think Welford has a particular
issue in that
the the reality is that the properties
that are being brought forward
are large-scale properties because they
fit well for if you will and there's no
real desire on the part of any developer
to address the housing need survey
results around a
uh around Bungalows the issue is that
whilst Welford and many other
communities have I think of my own Ward
have taken significantly higher numbers
than those planned in the current course
strategy regrettably we have to be
mindful of the fact that the the
inspector made it clear both in terms of
overall numbers and in terms of lsvs
that the numbers are a minimum not a not
a not a not a not a given at our over
delivery
um
there is a law of unintended
consequences that our over delivery
doesn't actually help us in that in that
way
um
and given all of that I think that it is
with it is regrettable that there are
really no planning grounds
to go to to to bring forward that are
substantive enough to warrant
um overturning the officer's condition I
would like however to see a some
condition around the access I am
concerned about the access and I'd like
to see a condition and if I could gain
support for it that the the access 3.7
meters I I get the bid about 45 meters
access but in reality
you know if there's a fire in that house
they need they need to be getting closer
than that that's why they asked for 3.7
along there uh that that be a
pre-commencement condition that the
access is secured of 3.7 meters along
its full length and I'd be looking for
support for a pre-commencement condition
around the access if possible I can't
see that in the current conditions that
is allowed for if officers can provide
some
confirmation or something in the notes
then I'll I'll live with that but I am
concerned uh because I have seen other
applications where doesn't actually get
built out and we're not going to go and
enforce that because it's too low down
the priorities so let's get it sorted at
the application stage so uh chair if you
can perhaps take some well first of all
don't get any do I get any sympathy with
that notion and if so then how can
officers help us with an appropriately
worded condition
I'm coming yeah through your chair um
there is condition 15 which requires
access to be surfaced with a bound
material and access wide and in
accordance with the submitted drawing I
don't know whether that addresses your
need I I think it is a condition
recommended by the highway Authority
rather than something that came through
from the consultation with the Fire
Safety Authority
um
I think these
yeah I think that's probably as much as
I could say
through you chair the question of it
being a pre you know a pretty
substantive you know actually having the
access nailed down as the first piece uh
how it offers us feel about that
I think this would be a compliance
condition it would be requirements of
the development to be developed in
accordance with the drawings which have
been submitted is is how and you confirm
they show 3.7 along the full length I
don't of them before me so I can't
confirm that at this stage I think in
those success I'd like to have if I can
gain support of members I'd like to
button it down in the decision
and I appear to have counselor Curtis
and councilor Perry in support of that
I'm getting a sense of the room I mean
we do have a proposal and a seconder um
with some additional conditions already
noted
um notwithstanding what councilor
Pemberton is Raising through you chair I
looked at the proposer in second or two
to acquiesce exactly what I was about to
do uh councilor
before I do that uh councilor Harvey
might have something to add but not on
that particular point
thank goodness
um can I just be clear in my
understanding there is the request from
the parish council that the material for
the driveway should be uh permeable and
do I understand that condition seven
has set out on page 31 would include
that or um
or
would he be under 15 or has that have
the officers accepted that that request
enjoy its attention to condition five
hush my mouth
oh I get this thank you very much I'm
glad we clarified that point now
um I'm going to address the points to
council Pemberton has raised uh he's
clearly concerned about the access for
emergency vehicles and has requested of
our proposal and secondary to consider
that in their proposal is that something
you are willing to accept
Jay yes I am
okay additionally myself Jeff
very good happy
um uh chair I think I probably just
voice a word
um
the application site encompasses the
land necessary to build the dwelling and
its Garden cartilage it doesn't
Encompass the whole of um
as far as I'm aware the access we know
aligns with the blue line boundary of
the applicant's ownership in such a
circumstance what we would need to
impose is something like a grampian
condition which would disallow
occupation of the dwelling until such
time and access of 3.7 meters wide
has been provided or we can confirm the
satisfaction of the Fire Authority would
that be acceptable to members that don't
work for me yep certainly seeing nods
and thumbs up for that one okay in that
case unless anyone has anything else to
add I think we can probably move towards
a vote yep very good
very good
yeah
trying to get I think we got there with
the wording
so the proposal is to Grant the
application in line with the officer
officer's recommendation with the
addition of a condition on construction
management plan and the widening of the
access
um wording of which to be delegated to
officers
all right can I see all those in favor
unanimous to mail notes sorry too many
papers in the air
number we got nine that's nine four
those against
one against
okay and then this committee resolves to
Grant application
2300123 ful Hillcrest Benton Road
Wilford on Avon
so we're now moving on to our last
application uh item number five which is
application 22 0 3 2 8 0 slash
29 the close Hampton Lucy
our presenting officer is Sarah flirty
and once you're ready feel free to start
thank you very much
thank you chairman
the application site is located within
the draft Builder Barry boundary of
Hampton Lucy as defined in the emerging
NDP
the site is an area of gardenland
associated with associated with the
existing dwelling at 29 the close and
can be seen by the red line in the
center of this plan
the pink line on this planet denotes the
conservation area boundary at the bridge
the site is outside
with a green circle next to the site
indicating a tree protected by a tree
preservation order the site's also in an
area of high archaeological sensitivity
this is a full planning application for
the demolition of an existing garage and
the erection of one dwelling here we can
see the existing and proposed site plans
the elevations of the proposed dwelling
can be seen on this Slide the dwelling
will be 6.6 meters in height and have
three bedrooms the host dwelling can be
seen here
if you can see my cursor the Gable above
the proposed dwelling to the rear
the proposed railing will be oriented to
face the entrance of the close
the application also proposes Works to
the host dwelling which is seen here
specifically the removal of a
side-facing first floor window scene in
the top left
which would then be relocated to the
front elevation which can be seen in the
bottom right
this image is taken facing the west and
shows the existing access and garage
with the side elevation of the host
dwelling seen on the left
this image is taking taken facing the
Northwest and shows the mature oak tree
adjacent to the site the garage to be
demolished can be seen in the background
this image is taken from Google Street
View and shows the two mature trees at
the entrance to the close with the tree
on the left this one here being the one
subject of the TPO true preservation
order
the existing access and garage at the
application site can be seen over here
on the right
chairman the principle of development is
acceptable however the impact on the of
The Proposal on the character of the
area and on the future health of a
mature tree have been found to be
unacceptable
the recommendation is therefore to
refuse the application for the reasons
detailed on page 43 of the agenda pack
there are no updates thank you
thank you very much Sarah okay so we're
moving to our first Speaker who is
councilor Alex Jones chairman of Hampton
Lucy Parish Council
hello counselor uh you have three
minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning and when you're ready take it
away
thanks Jack good evening everyone uh I
hope we won't take the three minutes up
and I'll keep this one quite short and
sweet
um
generally as a parish council we are
quite we're supportive of any infield to
meet our sort of housing needs
allocation
um in fact we've been looking at it with
our neighborhood plan we struggle to
find Eddie that we believe are suitable
hence they're not in the draft plan
um we are also supportive of personal
applications where we feel they're
appropriate this is not appropriate and
it's actually quite rare for us as a
parish council to object to planning
proposals within within the village for
for residential property
um
a final thing although not a planning
consideration it's a bit of a land
ownership consideration where you see
that Gateway
um in in the photo if you go to the
wider pictures another asset there that
there that's that's the one so you can
see that oak tree the land that
surrounds that oak tree is owned by
orbit
um and not the applicant and so
therefore there would be a question
about rights of access over that land I
know it's not a planning consideration
but at the end of the day there could be
a consent granted that actually you then
have some real issues over land access
um to to us driveway
um and finally I would just say that
actually our grounds for objection are
pretty much the grounds uh cited for by
the planning officer for refusal so I
wholeheartedly agree with them uh but I
would say that
um so thank you very much for your time
that is all I wish to say
thank you very much councilor well
within your time members do we have any
questions counselor Harvey
good evening
Tree on the left hand side of the
entrance to the close is has a TPO on it
was that
as a result of initiative from the
parish council and if so why did you not
seek a TPO on the right entry as well
um
with regard to the first one that has
the tp01 I'm not aware of the history of
that and whether it was the parish that
requested it the tree to the right hand
side so I.E adjacent to the proposed
development uh was subject to much
debate uh upon the previous sitting of
the parish council where uh eventually
after much debate it was decided that to
seek a tree preservation order for it
um but when when that was sought the
um the the conservation or the landscape
officer
um deemed the tree not to be of suitable
quality to actually have a TPO put on it
it was I think actually it's actually
picked up in
um boracultural reports about the
condition of the tree
etc etc and that that was some of the
reasons in and around why it wasn't
supported the or recommended that we go
for a tree preservation order
any other questions from a parish
counselor
no in which case I think you're free to
go thank you very much thank you very
much
okay our next speaker is uh Matt
Williamson who is the agent of the
applicant and Claire love who's the
applicant
welcome both
um now you've got three minutes between
you and my to understand Mr Williamson
you'll be speaking no no just three
minutes between you and Fred
I'm afraid that that uh
you only get three minutes each if you
have two other speakers who both both
speak against effectively so I'm afraid
it's just split between the two of you
um so
obviously here from the agent special
feature Architects
um from the plans report The Proposal
meets many of the required policy
thresholds for development being
acceptable and principal besides aspects
relating to the design and the tree
which we've already picked up on
I set out within the design and access
statement the home to design is based on
the traditional vernacular found along
the main road in the village which is
Church Street
while also bearing similarity to the
newly constructed medium site
development along the spinny which both
are directly adjacent to the close
the dwelling raises the aesthetic
quality of the close utilizing materials
found locally with carefully considered
ornament taken by the buildings within
the charlatan Humpty Hampton Lucy
Conservation area which are proposed
reports outside of but still reflects
the placement on the dwelling on the
side is located to enhance the view as
you enter the cul-de-sac setback by
directly facing the junction between the
close and Centerfield Street
a placement additionally reacts to the
existing number 29 its form being set
back behind the established front
building line and not extending beyond
the rear of its neighbor for privacy and
overshadowing reasons
the house is located as far from the
nearby tree as reasonably practical and
meets all relevant policy in relation to
providing suitable private Garden space
bin storage and car parking
the health of the tree has been
consisted considered from the outset of
The Proposal while it has no tree
protection order on it it's outside any
protections relating to the designated
areas and is widely agreed to be in
Decline and probably dying we have
worked alongside an arborcox specialist
to ensure that she's Health as much as
possible
the tree will have its trunk physically
protected during construction with
fencing and ground protection limiting
any impact to its structure
and fully installed all car parking hard
Landscaping will be built above the
existing ground level to have no impact
on the routes as per the Arbor Court
report and be specified to be permeable
which is an improvement on the current
situation
foundations will be specially designed
to protect the Integrity of the existing
root Network and demolishing the garage
building will in the words of the above
culturalist bring about a more conducive
environment for root growth and
establishment which in time could
potentially have a positive impact on
the overall health of T1
I suppose it's been carefully considered
to sit well within its surroundings on
its site as well as consider the health
of the tree for the remainder of its
life this application should be approved
thank you
thank you very much
very good
are there any questions for our
applicants
no in which case
um you're free to go thank you very much
all right we're now moving on to points
of clarification for uh oh wait I'm
terribly sorry getting ahead of myself
aren't I I had to make one mistake
jolly good
counselor Parry we have our Ward member
registered to speak you have five
minutes
um we'll give you a 30 second warning
and otherwise
you're free to go thank you chair and
you can be relieved I might be taking my
full five minutes
um Hampton Lucy is now part of the new
Welles born Northern rural award so I
have pleasure in sitting on this side of
the meeting for the first time
whilst I'm sure councilor Richards had
very valid reasons for supporting this
application
I wish to take the opposite view having
undertaken a site visit this week from a
public viewpoint
I know this particular part of the
village well and the key issues with
this application in my view is the
proposed site's location at the entrance
into the close just off snitterfield
Street together with the impact on the
oak tree
as such with any t-junction location
careful attention needs to be attributed
to the setting of its entrance the
uniformity of building lines and the
character and style of neighboring
properties
whilst 29 the close benefits from its
end of Street location the proposal for
an adjacent new dwelling following the
Dom demolition of the host willing
garage appears manipulated into the site
and consequently would be at odds with
other properties in terms of its design
and distinctiveness and is thereby out
of character
in my view it is therefore contrary to
cs9 in terms of its layout and
orientation together with the
sensitivity to the setting and existing
built form
in addition I do have major concerns
about the impact this development could
have on the oak tree on the right hand
side of your picture in view of his of
it it does have significance in this
part of the village despite not having a
TPO and in not the best of health
there are also concerns that the parking
position for the new dwelling would be
under this existing tree canopy which
could be unsuitable
Hampton Lucy's neighborhood development
plan is at an advanced stage of its
progression and highlights that infill
developments must follow established
building lines and be designed to ensure
that space between buildings are not
significantly reduced
whilst I acknowledge My Views will be
disappointing for the applicant my
reasons and support of the officer's
recommendation for a refusal are
mirrored in equal measure by Hampton
Lucy Parish Council
thank you members and if I may just
indulge there's a fantastic Festival in
Hampton Lucy on Saturday opening at 1
30. thank you members
well within your time thank you very
much councilor Perry
members do we have any questions for our
Ward member
that one from counselor Curtis what time
does the festival start okay
1 30. you got in there just before I
could tell you it's not relevant to the
application
all right well I believe there are no
other questions so um thank you very
much feel free to go
we'll now move on to points of
clarification for our officers and
councilor Harvey is straight in there
take it away
refer to page 38 the last paragraph
this location would be cramped and
contrived
um that does not allowance sound like
planner speak to me could you
um tell me what policies uh from the
core strategy or from the putative NDP
or anywhere else what do you re from
where do you get this description of
cramped and contrived that's the sort of
thing I might say but I don't really
expect you from you
a Crampton contrived of my own words but
I've assessed The Proposal against cs9
of the core strategy and the designers
distinctiveness policy and which as
you'll know requires development to be
sort of in keeping with the street
seeing uh consider local vernacular and
sorry David if you have some dad
when you say cramped I'm not arguing
with you and I may not disagree with you
but but I think the applicant is
entitled to be able to say cramped
because it's 10 square meters and it
needs to be 50 square meters or whatever
the relevant numbers are that was really
what I was after yes I I think what
we're trying to say is that it comes
across as overdeveloped I think our
understanding of the sort of vernacular
in this area is that they're you know
reasonable spaciousness of the front and
the sides of these dwellings and this
dwelling as proposed would be quite
close to its host dwelling and there'd
be relatively little space
other than for things like parking and
hard standing and the access and for
those reasons a plain English
description of it might be that it's
cramped and that they have worked the
space I think councilor Parry in her
comments said that they've manipulated
the building into this site and I think
that that was much of our same feeling
on on that as well
thank you chair
um we've heard from the applicant's
agent and also from counselor about the
oak tree not the one with the TPO on it
but the other oak tree
um
which
um we were told was not perhaps in the
best of health and maybe dying
um I got a couple of questions in
respect of that tree and the application
site and those are was a tree condition
survey provided to support the
application in respect to the condition
of that Oak Tree on the right hand side
and the second thing is
um could we see again please the um the
site plan which shows
um the parking area and the entrance and
how that might impact on the canopy of
the tree
sorry perhaps I'll answer your second
question first and we can see the
proposed site plan on the right which
shows the two parking spaces and then
you can see the crown of the tree in the
bottom right
yeah
um to answer your first question
um yes the applicants provided an
arboricultural arboricultural assessment
in support of the application
um here we've got a tree protection
route protection error plan and you can
see in the oranges the incursion that
the proposed dwelling would have into
that nominal RPA
um
that's helpful
entrance to the site was that exactly
can you show us yeah so you just coming
across yeah that area of the room that's
great area of the tree as well yeah
that's not shown on that plant shown
blue what's blue the blue indicates the
existing RPA incursion and then the
orange indicates the additional
incursion of the RPA that would result
because there's already a gate isn't
there so presumably you can already get
to the garage across that area right yes
thank you
any other points of clarification
in which case we can move to our debate
who would like to start councilor
Pemberton please uh thank you may I just
start by invite the show May I just
start by inviting members to a
two-center holiday Bedford has a market
starting at 9am on the High Street on
Saturday
um I'm now
and to assist counselor Harvey I'm aware
that uh that the presenting officer is a
fellow West Brom fan and therefore does
speak plainly and clearly please move on
to anyways and everybody will understand
uh I will also say that the officers
nailed it
absolutely nailed it in this one and I
recommend we follow the officer's
recommendation on this particular case
without any further debate if I can find
a second that
looks like a proposal I had councilor
Eden Nix
you found your second to cancel
Pemberton I agree it's uh it does look
over developed I think
um it doesn't follow the building lines
and
I am concerned about the tree but that's
outweighed by the other two concerns
I've got previously so happy to second
thank you very much councilor Harvey
I was immediately going to
make reference to the damage state of
the of the tree and the and that might
devalue the the officer's recommendation
however the projected life of this tree
between 20 and 40 years is longer than
mine so good luck to the tree
optimistic view from councilor Harvey um
thank you chair no looking at you it's
vastly overdeveloped and obviously it
does encroach on the building line and
um I agree with the officer's
recommendation on this
thank you very much are there any other
counselors mission to speak on this item
um yeah I think I'm very much in
agreement there
um
in which case we can move to a vote
um all those in favor of granting in
line sorry
refusing in line with the officer's
recommendations
that's unanimous
we've
okay then this committee resolves to
refuse application
22-03280 ful
now I don't believe
I don't believe we have any urgent
business
which case
um
there's no more items and we can close
the meeting thank you very much